ah
la unión europea quiere dar una vuelta
de tuerca a su política migratoria por
ello la comisión europea ha propuesto
reforzar los conocidos como retornos
voluntarios de migrantes es decir
retornar a los migrantes persuadirlos
para que vuelvan a sus países de origen
pero de forma voluntaria y sin forzar
los la comisión europea cree que es una
medida mucho más efectiva ayudarles en
sus retornos sus países y formarles y
también para poder encontrar un empleo
en sus países ahora mismo la comisión
europea quiere centrarse en ampliar los
acuerdos con los países de origen pero
también reforzar el papel de frontex la
policía europea de fronteras esta
policía se encargará sobre todo de
retornar estas personas de forma
voluntaria pero también en vigilar su
reintegración en sus países de origen la
política migratoria de la unión europea
siempre ha sido su asignatura pendiente
hasta ahora se han aplicado medidas poco
efectivas que analizan poco sobre cuáles
son las causas reales de la migración
[Música]
la gota migratoria hacia las islas
canarias frente a la costa noroeste de
áfrica levanta mucha polémica en españa
primero porque ya en lo que va del año
murieron 88 personas pero también porque
la llegada de pateras nos es a 4 mil
personas fueron rescatadas en lo que va
de año un 125 por ciento más que el año
anterior y los expertos avisan de que en
la llegada del buen tiempo pero sobre
todo la grave depresión económica que
sufren los países africanos se
traducirán en una afluencia más
importante y último problema pues es la
acogida de estos supervivientes que
algunas ongs califican de inhumana y el
mismo defensor del pueblo esta semana
pidió al gobierno primero pues mejorar
las condiciones de estos campamentos el
segundo el que se deje libre circulación
para los migrantes y califica de
inadecuada a la población de estas
libertades por el simple argumento de
evitar un efector llamada
[Música]
el problema migratorio es sin duda uno
de los retos más importantes de la
relación méxico-estados unidos la
oficina de aduanas y protección
fronteriza ha dado a conocer que cerca
de 5.000 migrantes son detenidos cada
día en la frontera común mientras que en
méxico el instituto nacional de
inmigración ha revelado que a la fecha
hay en el país cerca de 5 mil niños
migrantes en vísperas de una visita de
la vicepresidenta kamala harris para
abordar esta situación el presidente
lópez obrador insiste en su idea de que
estados unidos financie la aplicación en
centroamérica de su programa sembrando
vida para así generar empleo y a la vez
regular el flujo migratorio ya que
participaren sembrando vida según lópez
obrador sería una vía para obtener la
residencia y eventualmente la
nacionalidad estadounidense mientras
esto ocurre el tránsito migratorio no se
detiene con todos los riesgos que esto
conlleva un ejemplo cruento de esto
ocurrió en enero pasado el gamal y pass
con el hallazgo de 16 cuerpos calcinados
de inmigrantes guatemaltecos
[Música]